Here's our trusty book class again. And we're adding a method,
getSecondSentence. Last time we could just use the zero as the beginning, but
this time we're going to need to start where the first one left off. So we
calculate the beginning the same way we calculated the end. But then start
right after the period instead of at it. To get the end of the sentence, we'll
need to use a different version of the indexOf method. We're still looking for
a period. But now we want to start at the beginning of our sentence, that we're
working on. And now we use the sub string method the same way as we did before.
And return book text dot sub string from begining of sentence to end of
sentence plus one. I added a couple lines to the book tester, so we can
actually test our second sentence method, and now I'll run the book tester
again. Here's the result. I don't remember the second sentence by heart, let's
look at the Alice text again. It looks like the second sentences match, good
work.